in many ways and I'm gonna say this as a
compliment it is that and the reason why
my brother Steve had a crush on you you
know that he would lay in bed and jerk
off to you I mean that's a compliment
that's a very big compliment I was more
than that like he was in love he was in
love with you heart but there's a lot of
guys that asked about YouTube wooden
guard oh yeah yeah yeah guard oh I
bought her a dresser right but here's my
theory is is that the reason why my
brother did is because you have certain
traits like my mother
mm-hmm the way you dress your size your
energy yeah your energy you know it's
just like you just kind of loud and you
don't my mom used to we go to the mall
she I need to rest she would lay in the
middle of the [ __ ] mall I have a man
laying in the mall yeah that's Jenna
yeah they have no like social life
filter life filter right my mom didn't
teach me them yeah my mommy didn't ever
talk to either I used to get in trouble
like an in-school suspension for sitting
on the floor instead of sitting in class
on the chair mm-hmm because my mom
didn't ever tell me like oh that's
that's that's distracting or that's rude
and some people thought I was trying to
be rude and disrespectful and I yeah
like the floor is more comfortable I'm
still listening I'm still learning I'm
doing well just and then yeah I mean she
dry shaves at coffee shops
what's that she that she takes a razor
yeah with no shaving cream no soap or
water and she just dry shaves her armpit
no I didn't do that but you're right I
did when I first met yes you did I was
like what the [ __ ]
we're friends yeah I made gilbert hang
out with me about the first seven times
because i was like i love this dude and
he was he had this kind of energy just
like he didn't want to be near me and i
would just force him to meet but he
literally had a crush on you for like 15
seconds then you open your mouth and
start doing [ __ ] and bobby did too for
15 seconds 15 seconds then after that's
like yeah we'll be friends guys i should
come out with an album that's just
called 15 seconds yeah I do think that
that's how my life is though typically
there are men who I don't know what they
see in me they're attracted to me
they're drawn to me
like hunt me yeah and as soon as I turn
around like yeah yeah come get me
yeah something about it in in
relationships they're like we're done no
I know exactly what what why that is
Thanks it's a phenomenon that dudes lose
interest in her but she does this
intentional self friendzone she friends
owns herself even when she's attracted
to a guy all of a sudden she finds
herself like burping in his face the
first 10 seconds she meets him or she
doesn't she wants to be like her most
authentic self in her head she's like I
want them to know me yeah it's false
when I'm like hold that but you got to
lead with a little sexuality not saying
you're wrong yeah I'm just saying that
the reason I do it is because to me it
feels like I'm being false
it feels like I'm like oh well I I do
burp yeah but you don't want to show
like I have a lot of things a lot of
things that I could be authentically
myself like just air out my left [ __ ]
athlete's foot give me at a restaurant
you know I mean I feel like you do
though I know by my foot is but I would
never do that until I'm fully invested
in a relationship yeah i trapped her
first and then I aired out my left foot
Yeah right you can't just do that up
front as your opener sequel to the
Daniel day-lewis moving my left foot I
love you know be airing out my left foot
the poor the horror film Bobby's
favorite movie I love they love that
movie he's so good in that movie do you
win an Oscar for that I'm sure I feel
like he won an Oscar for every
everything that he's ever done one of
the best actors of all time
[Music]